robots sent from the future to protect
us the plot of Terminator 2 may be
science fiction but thanks to engineers
at Boston Dynamics the idea may not be
as far-fetched as we think come with me
if you want to live
this is PETMAN an anthropomorphic robot
designed to test the kind of search and
rescue clothing used during reactor
meltdowns or worse nuclear war the
company debuted an early version of
Catman in 2011 seen here going for a
stroll and knocking out some push-ups
almost two years later pet man still
enjoys walking on the treadmill but the
latest version has undergone a
significant evolution he now perfectly
emulates a human beings full range of
motion essential to testing clothing
made to withstand exposure to hazardous
chemicals it's just the latest
experiment in the company's line of
lifelike military innovations
you may remember cheetah a DARPA
commissioned robot that set a land speed
record of nearly 30 miles per hour
setting off military dreams of an ultra
fast companion for foot soldiers then
there was Big Dawg also a DARPA project
which Boston Dynamics set free to roam
the beaches of Thailand in a display of
its ability to carry heavy cargo across
tricky terrain as for pet man the
Pentagon reportedly hopes to use the
robot for more than just testing hazmat
suits it could be sent in on solo rescue
missions in the event of a biological
attack
you